et pour en parler nous sommes avec
gilles sacaze anciens cadres du service
action de la dgse bonsoir gilles sacaze
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france quel rôle selon vous pour les
renseignements ces temps de pandémie est
ce qu ils peuvent être déterminants
d'une manière ou d'une autre
comment au moins six résidences et le
monde ce ne serait pas concernée je
dirais dans cette dans cette période on
a une catastrophe sanitaire mondiale
avec des enjeux politiques et des enjeux
économiques majeurs je crois que comme
on en a pas eu en gros depuis les
conflits mondiaux
ça ça induit un certain nombre de crises
si vous voulez à la fois sur le plan
international dans la relation entre les
états elle vous l'avez évoqué dans vos
dents dans vos titres en termes de pour
arriver à je dirais acheter
prioritairement l'exemple italien a été
donnée les gérer les pénuries de masques
de matériel médical etc
donc il ya des risques de gouvernance
gérer de stabilité intérieure parce que
tout et tout est exacerbé en réalité et
de sécurité également intérieur nos
ennemis habituel donc pas disparu
ils sont ils sont toujours là et
certains voient ça a été annoncé
notamment côté des islamistes comme
l'affaiblissement d'un certain nombre de
pays comme une opportunité pour pour
agir
les tensions sociales également sont là
et elles sont encore une fois que ça
servait parce qu'on a on a des
gouvernements c'est valable en france
mais c'est valable partout qui peuvent
être discrédité ou déstabiliser dans
leur gestion de la crise
donc bien sûr les les territoires perdus
on le voit actuellement les territoires
perdus de la république pour reprendre
le terme désormais célèbre de georges
bensoussan tous ces problèmes là qui
étaient antérieurs existent ils sont
exacerbées les services s'y intéressait
déjà donc il
il s'y intéresse d'autant plus fortement
que que les problèmes les problèmes se
sont aggravés par la crise et il ya des
choses qui sont vraiment spécifique à la
crise qu'il faut qu'il faut également
gérer vérifier les informations qui nous
sont bonnes et on a vu avec la chine qui
nous sont données à la fois en termes de
chiffres etc
parce que c'est important pour pour
l'analyse on se rend compte un peu
tardivement que la coopération n'était
pas si fluide que ce qu'on croyait et
est également vérifié vérifier tout ce
qui est en termes de ressources
tout ce qui nous est proposé justement
j'ai le fagace vous parliez de la chine
on s'est tous dit alors sans regarder
des james bond que les services de
renseignement notamment français
évidemment mais pas qu'eux ont rapporté
1 les événements qui se passait en chine
très tôt pourquoi selon vous ça n'a pas
permis au gouvernement d'anticiper
peut-être mieux la crise je suis patient
enfin je sais pas quelle a été la
qualité je dirais des informations je
pense que tous les services occidentaux
on en sort on sous-estimé la capacité
des chinois à à retrouver leurs vieux
réflexes sur une crise sanitaire
peut-être sur d'autres sujets on est
plus attentif mais en matière de crise
sanitaire et nous intoxiquer parce que
clairement c'est ce qui s'est passé on a
quand même été intoxiqués pour des
raisons je dirais culturel du culte du
secret je probablement pour des raisons
également de politique intérieure donc
ce n'était pas forcément ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que c'était pas
forcément hostiles au départ mais
l'enjeu maintenant c'est de cesser la
sortie de la crise qui va être
conditionnés par la façon dont on va on
va gérer la crise les délégués des pays
qui s'en remettront plus vite que
d'autres
des pays qui en sortiront se
déstabiliser et c'est là que je dirais
les rivalités entre les différents états
entre la la chine entre les etats-unis
la france l'europe on a vu à quel point
la les relations
européennes ont été au sein de l'union
européenne ont été perturbés donc bien
sûr tout ça il ya des enjeux de conquête
derrière de conquête de marché
c'est le comment dire la tentation
d'intoxiquer avant et pendant la crise
les pays concurrents je dirais sans
parler des demis mais les pays
simplement concurrents économiquement
elle elle est grande elle n'est pas
nouvelle mais elle et les séquelles du
rader souvent il va y avoir d
effondrement économique il ya des enjeux
majeurs
il ya des pays qui se relève
difficilement ou très tardivement de
tout ça j'espère qu'à sedan vous parlez
des lutins contre la pandémie
on l'a vu dans notre petit clip
les services de renseignements qui
peuvent jouer un rôle notamment dans
dans le traçage des malades là on n'est
pas vraiment tous égaux en fonction des
pays n'est ce pas envoyer soir signant
bernard soir 6 me un ancien patron des
services secrets bien voilà en france
c'est compliqué les politiques bloc sur
ce genre de choses mais en tout cas
c'est l'un peut-être l'un des rôles des
renseignements se trace in cette
surveillance des malades
alors il ya il ya il ya déjà il ya comme
on dit il ya un phénomène culturel je
dirais qu est important c'est à dire que
la france c'est pas la chine s'est pas
non plus israël je pense que le la
population française accueil globalement
de façon assez négative cette cette
surveillance même moi si vous voulez qui
suis quand même de culture de
renseignements je je je pense qu'il ya
peut-être des urgences il
aujourd'hui on fournit pas les masques
ont fourni difficilement des tests on
est en difficulté sur les moins
maintenant mais on était au départ de la
crise en difficulté sur les lits en
réanimation et on va mettre en place
un outil de traçabilité des malades
alors qu'on sait même pas aujourd'hui on
n'est pas capable de comment dire
d'identifier de tester suffisamment de
monde pour savoir qu'il qui est
contagieux ou pas donc je pense qu'il ya
un phénomène culturel mais il ya aussi
une gestion des déchets dits bilité
faudrait pas aggraver je veux dire elle
à la crise de gouvernance et aggraver la
crise de confiance aujourd'hui quand on
vit en france avec des outils qui m'a
presque certainement opportun quand tout
le reste fonctionne aujourd'hui je pense
que on a suffisamment de choses basiques
qui dysfonctionnent pour se concentrer
là dessus est-ce que c'était presque la
façon dont chaque pays justement gère la
pandémie est très scrutées par les
services de renseignement notamment
français oui oui oui pour les raisons
que j'ai évoquées parce que c'est
important de savoir quelques quelles
seront les forces et les faiblesses à la
sortie de la crise des uns et des autres
de nos partenaires mais aussi de nos
concurrents il y aura aussi des
opportunités de marché il ya des remises
en question profonde qui seront faites
un j'espère qu'ils sont fait qu' en tout
cas devrait être fait en terme de
souveraineté en termes de capacité de
souveraineté on l'a vu sur le plan
économique vous avez parlé de la chine
on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup de nous pan de notre économie
dépend de la chine et que on n'a pas
forcément vocation à rester amis en
permanence eux mêmes peuvent vivre une
crise qui les met dans l'incapacité
encore une fois sans même parler
d'austérité qui les met dans
l'incapacité de nous fournir en terme de
capacité de résilience on s'est rendu
compte qu'on a on se rend compte qu'il
ya un certain nombre de choses qu'on
n'est plus capable de faire qu'on n'est
plus cas on n'est plus capable de tenir
à la fois en termes d'éducation pour les
individus les familles etc
on parlait de stock aujourd'hui la norme
c zéro stock est ce que on doit
continuer comme ça en terme de
de production même de denrées je dirais
sans parler d'autres technologies mais
ne serait-ce que de denrées de première
nécessité
voilà c'est la relation aussi est ce que
est ce que les bonnes relations
d'aujourd'hui le reste en cas de crise
on le voit au sein de l'union européenne
les paris qu'on fait sur l'avenir sur
son important je pense qu'on va on va
remettre en question un certain nombre
de choses et ça va aussi modifier
probablement la relation qu'on peut
avoir avec à l'international merci
gilles sacaze anciens cadres du service
action de la dgse d'avoir été avec nous